[Music]
that's a live look at
tokyo this morning and speaking of you
may have heard of a cool new cat that is
taking the city by storm
lucy craft has the story
the godzilla of felines has been
pussyfooting around shinjuku
a bustling commercial district in the
heart of tokyo
every few minutes giant cat briefly pops
into view
flicking his tail and gazing upon a
growing band of admirers below
for them the super-sized pet is the
cat's meow
with the pandemic we don't have any way
to chill out said this hotel employee
or dog people but the cat is so adorable
it's soothing
like most cats this one operates on its
own time with only
short appearances throughout the day
this bank worker said
that giant cat looks like it's ready to
pounce it's really powerful and cute
i loved it but i would have liked just a
few more seconds with the kitty
from its sixteen hundred square foot
perch the monster ball of fur
has its own live stream feed and twitter
account with seventeen thousand
followers
ultra high resolution curved video
signage is rapidly generating copycats
across asia last year the starship
enterprise appeared to fly out of a wall
and over the heads of shoppers in
chengdu china
and in taiwan an led cyclops
menaced pedestrians but here in japan
it's the pause that refreshes for
cbs this morning saturday lucy craft
tokyo the cat's fine i'm not trying to
want a cyclops reaching down
and those are all billboards i could get
behind yeah i could too
yeah i just don't want to see the litter
box